[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning thank you all for being
here from my right let me introduce who
I have with me and then acknowledge some
special friends to my right is Gareth
Rhodes who has been he works with the
Department of Financial Services but
he's been working with us in Albany
during this coronavirus pandemic to my
left Melissa de Rosa was secretary to
the governor to her left
Robert Mejia who was the state budget
director he doesn't smile much in
nowadays because the state budget is not
in great shape but when the federal
government does the right thing and
gives us funding we expect that he's
gonna smile that big smile again it's a
pleasure to be in Rochester with so many
of my friends who have done such great
work for the state former lieutenant
governor Bob Duffy who worked with me
when we first got started and has done
great work for the entire state of New
York Danny Wegman pleasure to be with
you workmen's is a great New York
corporation and then he's a great civic
leader and they've been very helpful
through this situation also thank you
for allowing us to do the antibody
testing at Wegmans that's been very very
helpful and we thank you for everything
you've done
and Nicole Wegman thank you pleasure
thank you for being on our New York
forward Advisory Board to help us going
forward and find our way through this
let's give you an update on where we are
today the total number of
hospitalizations is down you see that
curve coming down you see that mountain
that we went up now we're on the other
side of the mountain you start to see
the shape of the mountain
unfortunately the decline from the
mountain is not as steep as the incline
right and the big question for us in New
York and and every state of course the
nation has been how
fast and how low does that decline go
right how fast does the decline actually
happen and what is the lowest level that
the decline will reach unfortunately you
see that we were shaped we were hoping
for a quick up plateau at the top which
is what they talked about but a fast
decline you see the the climb is again
not as steep as the incline but it is a
decline and that's good news then that
change in total hospitalizations is is
down and that change in intubations is
down and that's always good news when a
person is it intubated roughly 80% of
the times there is not a good outcome so
the fact that the intubations is down is
a good is good news and then the other
end is how many new cases are coming in
the door every day how many new
diagnoses in kovat cases and that number
is also declining so not only are the
number of people in hospitals coming
down but the number of new cases coming
in the door is down and that's good news
because it had plateaued at about 900
statewide for a few days but this number
is is down at 700 and that's a good
number I would take this with a grain of
salt as they say because this is
reporting from yesterday which was a
Sunday and sometimes we get different
results on the weekend remember this
whole reporting system is just been put
in place this never happened before this
is now every hospital in the state
reporting every day for the first time
so it's a plus or minus across the board
this is the number that haunts me every
day and this number is not declining
anywhere nearly as fair
as we would like to see it decline still
226 PETA New Yorkers who passed away and
so we don't become immune we talk about
these numbers
it's 226 families right that's 226 wives
or brothers or sisters or children that
are now suffering the loss of a loved
one so that we remember them in our
thoughts and our prayers people are all
talking about reopening which we should
be talking about this is not a
sustainable situation closed down
everything closed down the economy lock
yourself in the home you can do it for a
short period of time but you can't do it
forever but reopening is more difficult
than the closed down the closed down was
relatively simple right you go into the
basement you throw the big power switch
and everything just goes down closed the
businesses stay at home it was a blunt
operation and one that was done all
across the country just stop everything
now when you go to restart the reopening
now knowing what we know it's more
nuanced you have to be more careful and
again no one has done this before no one
has been here before
so first start by learning the lessons
that we did learn through this
experience and second let's be smart
about what we do and I get the emotion
and I get the impatience and I get the
anxiety we all feel it when I say this
situation was unsustainable its
unsustainable on many levels it's
unsustainable economically it's
unsustainable personally a lot of
anxiety is now all through our community
we see it in increased alcoholism
increase substance abuse increased
domestic violence so this is a very very
difficult period and people want to move
on yes but let's be smart about what we
do and let's learn the
since one of the lessons is we have
never been here before and we didn't
really know what was going on
CDC releases a report and the last week
that says the virus was actually coming
to the East Coast from Europe everybody
was looking at China for all those
months trying to China China China yeah
China was last November December the
virus migrated from China while we were
all staring at China and with the Europe
and the strain that came to the United
States came from Europe we had people in
the airports stopping people from China
testing people from China the federal
government did a lot of testing a lot of
screening people getting off planes from
China yeah but meanwhile the people from
Europe were walking right past them and
that's where the strain came from that
was infecting this area and that's what
the CDC just learned last week and this
is going back to February right on one
of the most study topics ever again just
learn the lessons of what happened you
now add that piece of information on the
Europe trips and then you see the number
of flights that came from Europe during
that time where they landed and now you
it explains why you've seen the outbreak
in Chicago that you've seen why you've
seen the number of cases in New York
because yes the flights were landing
here people were coming from Italy and
UK and from European countries and
nobody thought to screen them nobody was
on guard and you add that to the density
of New York especially in New York City
and that virus just took off okay we
didn't know we didn't know now we do we
also can look back in history you look
at that 1918 flu pandemic that they talk
about the places that opened
too soon so that flew come right back
and by the way that flu was not one wave
that was three waves first wave second
wave third wave second wave was worse
than the first wave and you see watch
the other countries that went through
this before us right we're not the first
one down the chute there were other
countries that went down before us you
see they wanted to reopen also they were
feeling the pressure on reopening and
you study those cases and you see that
you've reopened too soon or you reopen
unintelligently and you can then have an
immediate backlash and that's not
speculation that is looking at other
countries and look at what what has
happened around the world and then you
talk to the experts who know listen to
what they're saying
doctor pouchy who I think is one of the
best voices and minds on this dr. Falchi
has been through this in in different
iterations he was one of the pioneers on
the HIV virus and AIDS and he says we
could be in for a bad fall and a bad
winter could be why cuz he doesn't know
he's not sure but could be for a bad
fall or bad winter okay so put all of
this in the in the equation and then
also acknowledge and actualize that the
truth is that nobody knows what happens
next and when it happens well how can
that be that nobody knows we're so
sophisticated we have so much
intelligence we have so many experts
this is the United States of America how
can it be that no one knows because no
one knows I speak to the best experts
globally globally and nobody can tell
you for sure now experts we look to
experts and we expect them to know so we
push them
No answer the question tell me when
what's going to happen in September
what's going to happen in December
sometimes the answer is I don't know
sometimes that's the honest answer I was
talking to my daughter's last night and
they said you know you say at your
briefings I don't know
how can you say that first I'm not
really sure they watch my briefings but
they're right sometimes I say I don't
know why because I don't know and if you
don't know say you don't know and I
speak again to the best minds in this
country the best minds around the globe
and they don't know so if you don't know
say you don't know it doesn't mean
you're not smart no reason to get
defensive I don't know when you know
what you don't know and admit it it will
actually keep you safe my daughters
don't quite agree with this yet but I
haven't given up on the concept know
what you don't know know when you don't
know what the future holds you can be
safe because then you can prepare for
different possibilities and that's where
we are we don't know but we will be
prepared for all possibilities so
reopening charter course with the best
information you have learning from the
lessons you have but be able to correct
that course depending on what happens
which means don't act emotionally don't
act because I feel this I feel that
because someone said well other states
are opening so we'll you must be able to
open if other states are open if we get
the anecdotal forget the atmospherics
forget the environment don't forget the
emotional look at the data look at the
measurements look at the science follow
the facts and that's what we've done
here from day one there is no gut
instinct this is look at the data look
at their science look at the metrics
move forward measuring
what you can and what you know and then
be prepared to adjust well I want
specificity I want to know for sure you
don't but there's liberation in knowing
that so let's do this intelligently
based on metrics and we'll see what
happens and we'll adjust to whatever
happens well what does that mean our
metrics you can measure this and we have
to measure this you look at that
percentage and the rate of
hospitalizations which we have right
that's the chart that goes up and down
you watch that hospitalization rate do
your diagnostic testing so you know how
many people are testing positive and you
can watch that rate going up or down or
flat do the contract tracing so after
the testing you follow up and you do
that contact tracing and you are then
reducing the infection spread by
isolating the positives if you do those
things you will control the rate of
transmission of the virus which is
everything
nobody says you're going to eliminate
the virus in the short-term no body but
you can control the rate of transmission
and if you can control the rate of
transmission you can control the rate of
transmission from becoming an outbreak
or an epidemic or overwhelming your
Public Health System that is the best
you can do so control the rate of
transmission to what they call one point
one or less one point one is every
person infects one point one other
people more than one other person if
you're doing that that is an outbreak
that means it's going to increase
exponentially and it's going to be out
of control as long as your rate of
transmission is manageable and low then
reopen your businesses and reopen the
businesses in phases so you're
increasing that activity level while
you're watching the rate of transmission
rate of transmission goes up stop the
reopening close the valve close the
valve right away so reopen businesses do
it in phases and watch that rate of
transmission it gets over one point one
stop everything immediately that's where
the other countries wound up they
started to reopen they exceeded the one
point one it became an outbreak again
they had to slow down rather than
starting and stopping you'd rather have
a controlled start so you don't have to
stop right and that's what you learn
from the other countries you reopen too
fast then you have to stop and nobody
wants to have gone through all of this
and then start just to stop again well
how does that happen first of all it's
not going to happen
statewide this state has different
regions which are in much different
situations than other regions in this
state and rather than wait for the whole
state to be ready reopen on a regional
basis if upstate has to wait for
downstate to be ready they're gonna be
waiting a long time so analyze the
situation on a regional basis okay and
you look at a region on four measures
the number of new infections your health
care capacity if the infections goes to
high you overwhelm your health system
now your Italy with people on Gurney's
in a hallway because your hospital
system can't handle it do your
diagnostic testing so you're seeing how
the infection is increasing or
decreasing and do the contact tracing
have that system in place so when you
test then you find a positive you trace
the contacts from that positive person
and you're isolating them to bring down
the rate and you
that on a regional basis that system has
to be in place for a regional basis how
do you start when can I start
reopening we look at guidelines from the
CDC which say a region has to have at
least 14 days of decline in total
hospitalizations and death on a three
day rolling average so you take a 3 day
average you have to have 14 days of
decline you can't have more than 15 new
total cases or 5 new deaths on a three
day rolling average this is telling you
that you are basically at a plateau
level that you can actually start to
reopen then you're watching the rate of
infection and the spread of the
infection and the benchmark there is
fewer than two new covered patients per
100,000 residents right it's based on
your population to account for the
variants in the different sizes of
regions across the state then anticipate
protect yourself from all possibilities
well what if we have a surge again never
fill your hospitals to more than 70
percent capacity leave 30 percent in
case you have a surge remember this
virus is tricky the rate of infection
per a person who gets infected today
shows up in the hospital 10 days from
today or two weeks from today
so that infection rate goes up you don't
feel it for two weeks there's a lag to
it you want to make sure you have 30
percent of the hospital beds available
in case you have that surge also learn
the lessons from before every hospital
has to have 90 days of PPE
for that hospital at the rate that they
have been using it during covert we
cannot have another mad scramble where
nurses and doctors don't have downs and
masks etc because the hospitals don't
have the necessary stockpile so make
sure every hospital has the stockpile on
the testing we have done really
remarkable work on testing 1 million New
Yorkers have now been tested believe it
or not
and the CDC coronavirus task force for
the White House recommends that for a
region to reopen you have 30 tests for
every 1000 residents ready to go
so what testing capacity do we need for
a region to reopen you have to be
prepared to do 30 tests for every 1000
residents New York is doing more tests
than any country in the state by far
New York is doing more tests than any
country on the globe per capita so we're
way ahead and testing but it doesn't
matter what we're doing statewide to
open a region that region has to have a
testing capacity of 30 per 1000 the
National Guard has been doing a great
job for us in putting together testing
kits and distributing testing kits and
we want to thank them very much but we
have to have those tests and we have to
have what they call tracers contact
tracers in place and Mayor Bloomberg has
been very helpful former mayor of New
York City in putting together this
tracing system this has never existed
before on the scale a group of people
who literally trace contacts from a
person who's positive who did you have
dinner with last night who did you have
dinner with two nights ago who might you
have been in contact with and then
contacting those people to say to you
have any symptoms if you do you should
know you were with John Smith John Smith
tested positive he said he went to
dinner with you you should be on alert
that old tracing system has never been
done not only in this state but in this
country so this that all has to be set
up and it has to be done once that is
all done then you can talk about
reopening businesses well which
businesses do we open first you open
businesses first that are most essential
and pose the lowest risk okay most
essential and the lowest risk phase one
we're talking about construction
manufacturing and select retail with
curbside pickup they are the most
essential with the lowest risk second
phase professional services retail
administrative support real estate third
phase restaurant food services
accommodation fourth arts entertainment
recreation education
remember density is not your friend here
large gatherings are not your friend
that's where the virus tends to spread
that's why those situations would be
down at the end and then we need
businesses to also really imagine how
they're going to do business and get
ready to protect their workforce to
change their physical environment to the
extent they need to and to change their
processes to make sure people can
socially distance people remain at a
safe in a safe environment and that's
going to be up to businesses to come up
with ways to reconfigure their workplace
and their processes to make this work
and that's business by business
government can say these are the
standards but a business is going to
have to figure out how to do
that when you look at the state there
are some regions that right now by the
numbers pose a lower risk some that pose
a higher risk we can tell you by region
right now of those criteria that we went
through which ones are in place for
which region so which ones have the
right hospitalization the right testing
regimen the right contract contact
tracing regimen and which ones still
have work to do in those areas and this
is going to be region by region and each
region has to put together the leaders
in those respective areas who put
together this system and monitor this
system literally on a daily basis so
they're getting all that import all
those specifics all that data and then
day by day they're making a decision as
to how to proceed with reopening based
on the data based on the facts and
that'll be a little different for every
region in the state may 15th is when the
statewide pause order PA USC not PA WS
the pause order the pause order was
stopped all businesses stay at home that
expires on May 15th May 15th regions can
start to reopen and do their own
analysis but these are the facts that
they have to have in place to do it
start now
don't wait to May 15th don't call me up
on May 15th and say well the pause order
expired I want to open because I'm gonna
ask you the questions I just asked I
just presented do you have a healthcare
system in place is your health system
ready can your hospitals handle it do
you have testing in place the AB Trey
in place have you talked to the
businesses about how they're going to
reopen so we have a couple of weeks but
the this is what local leaders this is
what a community has to deal with to
reopen safely and intelligently in my
opinion this can't just be we want to
get out of the house we're going No
let's be smart let's be intelligent
let's learn from the past let's do it
based on facts you know we are at a
different time in place government is
fundamentally in a different position
than it was just a couple of months ago
this is for real
now right government politics it's not
about optics it's not about celebrity
it's not about press releases it's not
about what I put on Instagram yesterday
this is about government leaders
performance their expertise this is a
situation where their competence and
their ability can be the difference
between life and death literally and
what the governments have done federal
state local what we've done in this
state has literally saved lives
we reduced all the projected
hospitalization rates dramatically by
about a hundred thousand New Yorkers 100
thousand fewer New Yorkers were
hospitalized than they predicted 100,000
think about that if we had 100,000 more
people in our hospital system first of
all our hospital system would have
collapsed
if the projections were true if we
didn't change those projections and we
literally saved lives how many of those
100,000 would have been hospitalized and
would have died so we've done great work
at a tremendous cost and tremendous
hardship but we've done great work
we just have to remain vigilant and
smart and competent going forward and
that's what New York tough means New
York tough means we're tough but we're
smart were disciplined we're unified and
we are loving and it's the love of
community and love of each other and
respect for each other which is what has
gotten us through this and will continue
to thank you very much for taking the
time to be here thank you for the social
distancing questions for myself or any
of my colleagues mask-wearing I said
look I believe this is the this is a
time for sort of honest straightforward
talk I said that I think it's
disrespectful of people not to wear
masks I mean think about it you see all
these commercials on TV we thank you to
our heroes thank you to the nurses thank
you to the doctors thank you to the
transit workers thank you to the police
officers and we should be thankful right
they went to work so all of us could
stay safe and go home the look the least
gratitude you can show is at least wear
the mask so you don't infect more people
who place more of a burden on the
hospitals and the nurses and the doctors
who were all saying thank you for your
your great service you really want to
say thank you
then respect them and respect their job
and wear the mask so you don't infect
people well I don't want to wear a mask
it's not that big a deal and by the way
you don't wear a mask for yourself you
wear a mask to protect me
I wear a mask to protect you we owe each
other a certain amount of reasonableness
and respect in society and I owe you
that level of respect that if I'm sick I
should wear a mask
local governments have the ability to
enforce and to penalize that's up to
local governments but do I think local
government should be enforcing it and
should there be sanctions yes yes
because it is a public health emergency
you know this is not just do me a favor
this is a public health emergency and
it's a statewide order that I put in
place that I'm proud of and local
governments have the responsibility to
enforce it and part of their right
the illegal right is they can have a
penalty or a sanction that they impose
so Rochester can have one penalty you
know you can be appropriate to the to
the community New York cities in a
different situation but yeah I think
local government should enforce it and I
think there should be a penalty because
you could literally literally kill
someone you could literally kill someone
because you didn't want to wear a mask I
mean how how cruel and irresponsible
would that be yes yes you don't have to
wear and no one said wear a mask all the
time right wear a mask if you may be in
a situation where you can't socially
distance you go for a walk in the woods
you don't have to be wearing a mask you
come to a point even from your walk in
the woods where you're going to be in a
parking lot or there's an entrance and
an exit and you may run into other
people wear the mask you can have the
mask down when you're walking in the
woods but now you see someone coming the
other way I'm gonna pass by the other
person you put the mask on I mean it's
it's the least that we can do right
everyone is killing themselves people
are working 24 hours a day show some
respect
show some basic modicum of respect
yeah putting putting all of these new
systems in place is an incredible task
and you know Society now we have a
temptation to blame well who's to blame
who's the blame nobody is to blame that
we don't have testing capacity for
millions of Americans we've never done
this before
our testing system was basically for the
flu test or strep or some other blood
test when the doctor would send you to a
lab to get a blood test
we never had a testing system in this
nation that could do this volume so this
whole thing is the Scramble and it was a
scramble between the federal government
in the States who's supposed to do it
who's responsible I had a good meeting
with the president a while back where we
sat down and we said look the states
controlled the labs we have about 300
labs in in New York State we regulate
them the state should be responsible for
what they can do and we need the federal
government to help where they can
the supply chain issue of reagents
manufacturing etc that is an
international supply chain ironically so
much of this stuff comes from China
it's like incredible on the testing the
reagents the chemicals as well as the
PPE when we were looking for masks and
gowns everything was in China but the
federal government has assumed the
responsibility of that international
supply chain the reagents etc this
states sort of take over at the state
line but that supply has increased and
we are distributing it and as you saw
we're doing more testing than any other
state or any other country per capita so
we're coming online very very quickly
but we still have more to do
yeah they're going to get guidance on
what the what plan they need to reopen
schools which is basically the analog to
what a business needs right I want to
reopen my manufacturing company okay how
do you do it and keep people six feet
apart how do you do it in the cafeteria
how do you do it then the transport how
do you run your business in a way that's
going to now meet the social distancing
guidelines same thing for a school part
of the issue for our school was just the
the gatherings in the school you have 25
students in a class how do you put 25
students in a class in their 6 feet
apart I mean look at this space right
even these press conferences you need
for 20 people you need you know a
tremendous sized room how how would you
do that in the school how do you
socially distance students do you need
more classrooms which means they need
more teachers how do you serve lunch
what do you do about the bus how do you
keep fewer students on the bus so those
kinds of details have to be in the
reopening plan they'll get guidance on
that but it's going to be easier said
than done especially for a school
because think about the problem is the
gathering a school is a gathering that's
what it is
yeah look I get the whole liber8
movement there's no reason for a closing
of anything just open everything up and
let everybody go do whatever they want
to do I get that argument I hear it I
understand it I'm sympathetic to it you
know everybody wants out I also know the
facts of what has happened to the places
have who have done that and what you
suggest that was all those countries
that saw saw a spike in the number of
cases right afterwards saw a spike in
the infection rate sort of spike in the
hospitalizations or spike in the number
of deaths and I would like to see as few
New Yorkers pass away as possible so yes
people want to get out on the other hand
we want to do it in a responsible way
and that's the whole question
no 80 and 90% of us don't get the
coronavirus nobody has gotten the
coronavirus before some people say well
this is like a flu yeah it's not like a
flu even eighty to ninety percent of us
don't get the flu right but this is a
different beast that we're dealing with
and we learned that the hard way
you don't hear anyone saying anymore
this is like the flu right that was back
in January February that was before we
had 18,000 people in our hospitals in
New York this is not a flu let's take
one more yes
yeah this is a national problem we have
unemployment systems states run the
unemployment system in this case we have
a lot of federal benefits that are
running through the unemployment system
the unemployment system was set up with
phone operators and a website to handle
like thousands of calls thousands of
input we now have millions of inputs it
is overwhelmed every state unemployment
website office etc I talked to all the
governor's on these conference calls
they're all struggling to deal with a
number of unemployment claims federal
government then just passed a piece of
legislation several weeks ago that had
additional benefits for people which
then required new signups and then it
brought more people to the websites etc
we have hired over 3,000 people to
actually run our unemployment service
our website and to handle the telephones
3,000 people which is just incredible
just for the unemployment line and we've
made great progress there is still for
some people a delay because you do have
to document and certify that the person
is eligible you just can't be just to
somebody close up and you Bob Duffy
calls and you say okay and you send them
a check federal law and common sense
requires that you affirm certain
information the good news is even if
there's a delay on the website it
doesn't cost you any money when you get
the check the check is from the date of
your eligibility even though the website
can be a pain in the neck to deal with
but I'll ask Melissa de Rosa who has
been overseeing this if she has an
update on the unemployment site and this
is actually very important in
commissioner
is gonna do a call later today to brief
out on the latest what we found in the
last several days is that a lot of the
people who are in pending status have
not gone on and certified their
unemployment status which is a separate
process from going through the
application so you file the application
you do the phone call you process
through but then you have to go into the
website into your account and certify
that you're unemployed and that's
something you have to do every week by
Saturday so you can either do it on your
website account or you can call there's
two separate numbers for unemployment
insurance it's eight eight eight five
eight one five eight one two and four
pandemic unemployment insurance it's
eight three three three two four OH
three six six and you have to do that
every single week and certify that you
are still unemployed and eligible to
work and then they process that
information so we sent out 90,000 emails
over the weekend to a batch of people we
identified that we're stuck in that
pending status because of that and as I
said Commissioner Reardon is gonna be
doing a more detailed call this
afternoon to continue to get this
information out to the public but that
is the number one thing that I would
recommend to those people who are still
sitting in pending status yes priority
status and just to punctuate one other
thing the governor said about the flu
the one big difference between corona
virus and the flu is that the flu has a
vaccine so for those people who are
still making that comparison I'd like
you to consider that
but you don't know what on the flu
vaccine a corona virus you don't know
what percent is gonna wind up getting it
nobody does and the experts don't know
either well that's not true
but yeah let's say it is true that the
overwhelming number of people who get it
don't die yeah
okay yeah that's fine unless you're the
person who dies then it's not so fine
yeah the the nursing homes have seen in
many ways the most intense issue here
and when you think about where this even
started it started in a nursing home in
Washington of Washington the vulnerable
population our senior citizens people
with comorbidities compromised immune
systems and a nursing home is a
aggregation of those people and that's
how it started and that is where it is
most dangerous in the nursing homes I
understand that I understand the nursing
home staff has been doing doing the
people who staff these nursing homes
have been doing a fantastic job because
it really is very difficult and we had
to put some precautions in place that
are just so harsh I mean we can't have
we said no visitors to a nursing home
during this entire time I mean just
think how harsh that is right but all it
takes is one person to walk into that
nursing home with a virus and then
you're off to the races so we're doing
everything we can the nursing homes are
working very hard we also announced an
investigation with the Attorney General
and the Department of Health to make
sure the nursing homes are doing what
they need to do many of them are
privately run but this state can
regulate them they have to notify
families etc so we're doing an
investigation on that but remember the
basic premise of the nursing home the
nursing home can only accept or keep a
patient if if they can provide adequate
care for that patient if they have a
kovat patient or non kovat patient but
they can't provide adequate care for
that person it is their obligation to
transfer the person if they can't find
the place to transfer the person it's
their obligation to call the State
Department of Health and the State
Department of Health will transfer the
person we have facilities
for kovat nursing home residents we have
some facilities that are just Fork Ovid
positive nursing home residents so we
have those facilities available if a
nursing home can't care for a co vyd
resident called the Department of Health
the Department of Health will transfer
the patient period and that
responsibility is on the nursing home
they have to know who they can care for
and who they can't care for if they
can't care for them for any reason my
staff is out sick I don't have the PPE
I can't quarantine I can't isolate for
whatever reason they have an obligation
to call the State Department of Health
and say I have to transfer this person
and we have existing facilities and beds
for them but the nursing home has to
make that determination
and if they are caring for people or
they have people who they're not suited
to care for then they're violating the
state policy and that's part of what
this investigation is going to look at
so I've said the nursing homes before I
say it again if you cannot provide
adequate care then that person has no
business being in your nursing home and
we do have facilities and we do have
beds that can care for nursing home
residents and do it well and do it
safely last point I'd like to make the
today we're talking about what local
government officials have to do what
each region has to do to be ready May
15th is a possible reopening if you're
ready this is how you're ready learning
from the lessons on the science on the
facts but this is a situation where yes
government is first and foremost in a
position where they have to make
decisions and perform and do it well and
competence matters and professionalism
matters and will hold government
officials accountable
I want to be held accountable hold
government officials accountable but we
also need local officials we need our
hospital administrators to be a big part
of this and we need every citizen to be
part of this you know who's going to
keep you safe
you are you are not me you are by your
actions you know it's gonna keep your
family safe your family and you are by
being responsible and reasonable in this
situation and then you know how we keep
each other safe by our individual
responsibility and respect by wearing
the masks by maintaining the social
distancing that's how we get through
this every body has a role to play here
there was no pointing fingers nobody's
been here before it's no one else's job
it's all of us together and that's what
has worked so well so far we just have
to stay at it it's been an honor to be
with you thank you very much
[Music]